if you were to think about what you want
this journey to look like
how would you express that i want to
walk away
with like a better sense of like
being okay with like letting the world
know
who i am this show is emotional
it's inspiring it's uplifting richie
tell me for people who maybe
do not know what shine true is all about
can you break down what the series is
about for me
well shine through is
a premier docu series that lucas and i
happen to be
the incredible host of we travel
around north america connecting with
young people
of the trans gender non-conforming
community and basically giving them
tools to affirm their identity and
walking through dysphoria walking
through anxiety
and really working as a queer family
to uplift their spirits and give them
the ability to show up
feeling like their authentic self my
gender dysphoria has gotten
really bad i dress to conceal my body i
want to be comfortable
expressing myself lucas tell me had you
met richie beforehand because i feel
like there is
chemistry between the two of you as
hosts and that really can't
be faked and you two just really seem to
click
was that a pun on my old band
i had never met richie and then when we
did meet it was like family
i don't know what it is if it was that
the universe aligned us
and that's how it worked out but i also
think that
when you're queer you tend to have a
familiarity with folks
that might be a little bit different
because it feels like family she's
such a wonderful human being and so
smart
it's not all just looks you know she's
not just that queen of the runway
she's also a queen emotionally she's
such a good human being and
brought so much to the show and to these
to these young folks we're gonna give
you all the tools you need to own your
identity
and you don't have to make up your mind
about who you are
ever when you're working on a show like
this richie it's emotional for those who
you are helping
but it must be so emotional for you as a
host
it's just hard i'm still figuring it out
for myself every night you know when we
would
rap shooting i would
be filled with so many thoughts and
ideas because it's such a
emotional journey not only for
our subjects but for us as well you know
i definitely see the world
even more brightly now a lot of people
think that
fashion is vain how has fashion inspired
you throughout your own journey in my
journey as a trans person as a trans man
i started
when i was around 32 and i came out and
because i was a singer
i was told that i wasn't going to be
able to go on testosterone at the
beginning
because i might lose my voice and the
only tool
that i had for five years to express my
my gender and the way i felt internally
was through fashion
so for me i will actually say that it
wasn't vanity
in the least it was literally
life-saving for me and i think for queer
folks
specifically it is such a way to tell
the world
who we are and to sort of communicate
that message
to people so that they sort of walk in
with a little bit of who we are already
when when we walk into the situation my
identity as a trans man has changed
i call myself trans bodied now and i
call myself a man
mostly i just call myself lucas lucas
you were the first out
trans man signed to a major record deal
which is
history making that is history right
there every time i hear that being said
that i was the first i would trans man
sign to a record label deal it always it
still hits me in this very strange way
because i
i see myself as just like you know just
like a regular guy or whatever
i'm honored that i had the capacity and
the privilege to be able to do that i
had kids tell me that
they've never seen somebody who was like
them and that it literally had saved
their lives
and that's something that i hold with a
lot of responsibility
and something that i learned coming into
doing this
show as well that there are so many of
us out there that need that
representation
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos